here we are we are about to release a
season 5 of worth it
we've done for season 7 it sounds like
Chewbacca you guys asked a lot of
questions you never give in here so
we're finally doing a Q&A video why not
take some time to answer some of your
most burning questions about worth it
the behind the scenes even behind the
curtain the secrets we thought that we
would eat something while we did it
making peanut butter and jelly
sandwiches to jam from squirrel
Katherine Janet and squirrel and this is
bread from Republic from a spaghetti
episode mmm I took the first bite I was
scared I couldn't bite it off but I just
aborted mission and give it all my mouth
we have a worth it
Instagram account its BuzzFeed worth it
and we're gonna now answer some of the
most popular questions on our intranet
question number one how did you guys
meet there was an unscripted ish
department at the time that you worked
on and somebody on that team was looking
for a new unscripted food show and you
were tasked with coming up this on the
road food travellish show like city
guide show I was like added to that show
to help produce him like the character
on the sauce is incredible it's
whimsical
is a hot dog sandwich and what are your
thoughts on pineapple pizza he's a hot
dogger sandwich yes on three one two
three
no hey it's a hot dog sandwich um says
no and what are your thoughts on
pineapple pizza Pro or negative on three
one two three
at Julia Doral how do you say Andrew's
last name so my last name looks hard to
pronounce but it's actually very easy
pronounce it's ill Nikki what was the
most fun worth it video to film um you
know it was really fun is when we went
to Seattle to eat some salmon cuz we
were just like on a jolly road adventure
you know it was like a fun new place I
was blown away by the autumnal glory of
the Pacific Northwest I would have to
say sushi not part one though mmm teaser
alert that's all I'm gonna say about
that not really a great food to talk
through who else is on your team I don't
think you guys are mean enough to stick
Adam with all the work great questions
glad you asked because over the years we
have had so many people who have
contributed the show in so many ways
that has just made worth it what it is
today
as you know we make this show here at
BuzzFeed where there's a ton of great
people that help and support us make
what we make like there's a research
team that makes sure that we're factual
is a legal team that makes sure that
everything we do is legal at least what
you see on camera hey there's I mean
there's a production team helps with
scheduling and getting us to places on
time a whole post-production support
team this season we have an extra
special additional person who's name is
Annie you're gonna see her in a bunch of
the videos so if you ever hear that
trademark laugh in the background
you know what is the craziest thing that
happened off camera that we haven't seen
there's been some moments yeah this one
time and that is probably the worst
thing that's happened on set what
happened to that 1000 cinnamon rolls
you owed Adam bianchi on the Fried
Chicken episode that wasn't a fried
chicken episode that was a game-day
foods yeah yeah
oh yeah you owe Adam a thousand cinnamon
I do or $1,000 cinnamon roll Adam if you
finish that I bought you a thousand
cinnamon rolls if you bought eat that
I'm going to not give him all 1,000 at
once I'm gonna kill him slowly one at a
time so starting today so how many have
you given him number one this is me uh
starting my quest to pay off my debt
that's one down put the ticker on the
screen we've eaten like ten dollars
worth of jam already
how does Andrew feel getting killed off
by Ryan and Shane
I feel fine about it I mean they killed
me they drowned me in a pool
insult did he just die did he just die
they'll get theirs what is one food you
would never do an episode four by Abby
Riggs
I mean there's lots of answers to this
question because the food just doesn't
make sense at different price points
atoms it's fighters and a theory
probably you know crickets I would
probably say peanut butter and jelly how
is Adam doing and does he get enough
food em do you want to answer for
yourself if you want me to take this fun
you're gonna answer how he's doing well
I'm not gonna answer that but Adam is
currently eating a Peter Byrne enjoy how
are you doing and now the final question
have you ever disliked the food or any
part of the experience from places that
you've eaten act we go to three
restaurants that are already worth it
we're really just trying to find the
best food at three price points and so
there really hasn't been anything that's
just like not delivered you know in its
given price tier I've definitely enjoyed
every experience it was worth trying for
$2000 called Pizza to me because I got
to see what that was like this was fun
we can do it again we're gonna have to
add some more Jam now pan over there
very special news we have merged sick
emerge heading your way
it's available now we'll see you next
week on season five six episodes you
want to reveal next week's episode
indeed teaser it's nots gonna be small
and it's not gonna be a vegetable
medium fish guess again
hey unsolved is on a new channel and now
you're part subscribe here that was my
part